au global dans le département des
yvelines les binômes au rassemblement
national ont récolté plus de quarante
six mille voix soit 14,82 % des
suffrages
c'est la deuxième force politique
derrière le rassemblement des
républicains de la droite et du centre
et pourtant les résultats sont décevants
celle des binômes se maintiennent au
second tour on sait que parmi les
élections qui n'attire pas des élections
régionales et départementales sont les
premières c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous avons souhaité nationaliser le
débat pour que les électeurs les
sympathisants de marine le pen se
déplace malheureusement ça n'a pas été
le cas c'est resté une élection de
notables locaux
exemple de cette déception à poissy le
binôme caroline carton et didier rouxel
récolte 12 41%
contrairement aux scrutins de 2015 il ne
se qualifie pas pour le second tour on
accumule les défaites après des fêtes
autant vous dire que je suis déçu mais
autant vous dire que au sein du
rassemblement national je suis issu
d'une famille qui se bat pour l'union
des droites on n'est pas entendus et
voir on évince et donc je me pose
beaucoup de questions sur le devenir
je me suis déjà mis quelque part en
retrait et et je ne sais pas si demain
je serai toujours au rassemblement
national celle satisfaction dans les
cantons de mantes-la-jolie et bonnières
sur seine
mathilde andraud et cyril notes se
classe en seconde position derrière
pierre bédier et nathalie pereira même
position pour monique fureur et laurent
maurin derrière le binôme joseph jean et
patrick stefanini ce seront les quatre
représentants du fn au second tour
c'est une satisfaction bien sûr dans le
contexte un peu un peu difficile que
nous vivons
au niveau national et donc y compris sur
le sur le canton de bonnières nous
appelons véritablement tous nos
électeurs
un sursaut dimanche prochain pour battre
patrick stefanini le rassemblement
national semble avoir souffert de
l'abstention
le taux atteint 66% pour les élections
départementale des yvelines